- By the way, can somebody do
a quick quant run on how much
of the vlog has been in the car?
♫ I was down on my luck lookin' at the top
♫ I was on meds they wanted me to flop
♫ My own friends and
family tellin' me to stop
♫ Going insane seeing every doctor
♫ I been drinking too
much, thinking too much
♫ Everybody tell me I was dreaming to much
♫ I remember when music
ain't never paid me two bucks
♫ Life is a battle and battles too rough
♫ Doctors told me i should take my pills
♫ For a bit I couldn't even pay my bills
- You're going up?
- Going up. Gonna talk to
D. Rock right quick.
I'll see you man, take care.
Just got off call with one of the sharks,
and just living the dream.
I wanna start doing this
more often in the vlog,
which is addressing opportunities
for a little bit of a rant
or a thought or three
cents, better than two,
around the emails that I read.
On these long flights, I
read a lot of your emails.
I can't respond to all of them,
getting thousands and
thousands a week at this point.
But I read them and I gather
thoughts and I try to get back
to some of you and some of you
get the emojis and the hearts
and the thanks and the
XOs and I send them to
some people on my team and
blah blah blah blah blah.
Anyway, theme of this flight:
people are asking for help
because they're stuck.
So many of you are stuck
cause you're not happy
with what you're doing and
something emerged to me,
and let's do a cool edit here D. Rock,
let's put the words right here.
It's either patience or it's action.
Like indecisiveness, sitting on it,
not doing anything about
it, is just not an option.
You can't fix being fucking
upset if you just sit there,
complain, and ponder all day in your desk,
or in class, or in your room,
because mom, or the teacher,
or the boss isn't doing the right thing.
The answer to literally
190 emails that I just got
is one of two things: either you wait,
and you're patient about it
and you just hold your breath,
eat shit, and come out the other side,
and eventually do something about it,
or you quit, or you tell
them to go fuck themselves,
or you do something about it.
You start.
You start tonight.
You don't watch TV,
you don't hang out, you don't
sit in your room and ponder,
you don't watch nine million
different motivational videos,
you just do.
The answer to the question, my friends,
is patience, or action.
- There's only two people I followed
or watched through this process,
it was you and Casey Neistat
cause I'm all about...
We have the same type of thing, it's like,
inspire, motivate, grind, hustle.
That's all.
- Two peas in a pod.
- Exactly, so just to meet--
- I'm flattered, man.
- That's good enough for me.
- It's a collab, you
know, to be on the vlog,
and then you be on my vlog.
- 100%. I love that stuff.
- So that's it.
I mean, I was talking to Tyler and D. Rock
and they were like, "Yeah,
you got 5-10 minutes,"
and I was like, "Oh dude, I'll
see you, that's all I need."
- Gimme both cameras, D. Rock.
I've never done a double camera.
Am I good?
- Yeah, you're good.
- Casey, it's me, hey.
Real quick, we're gonna meet this man.
This special kid.
This dude's doing it right.
I just asked him, I really
wanted to do something for him,
he's like, "Just one thing. Casey."
I know I'm putting you out like that,
but I'm calling you out, Case.
I'll text you in a little
bit, let's make it happen.
Are you gonna come to New York?
- I'm down, I'm down to come to New York.
- Casey, I love you.
But what I think matters most,
you know, this is gonna be
good advice for both channels,
you can't over-manipulate just
for the success of the metrics.
Once you let the math take
over the art, you're dead.
Like the soul has to come first,
you have to be thoughtful,
you can't just throw it up
there and be like, "Ooh."
But if it ever trumps the soul, you lose.
- Well I mean, that's the
thing I've always been telling
my viewers and people,
is that you have to be
100% passionate with what you do,
cause there's nights
where you don't sleep,
where you go crazy, and the
only thing that keeps you going
is your love for it.
'Cause you know, it's the same thing.
- I believe it the most
man, but I believe in it.
I got lucky.
I hated school so much--
- Same here.
- That I know the reverse.
I know what it feels like.
Like, I'm so special with
hard work and passion now,
I was super not special when
it wasn't the right zone,
and I just generally think
there's millions of people
sitting and watching this right now
that are all-time special.
Painters, cooks, teachers, you know.
Recording artists, painters,
business men and women,
or corporate executives,
who are trying to be entrepreneurs.
It's about the matching.
I genuinely think that every
single person that we think
as famous would have not
been famous and great if they
picked the wrong thing.
- Yeah.
- I just don't know if I think
Beyonce would be the greatest
WNBA player of all time.
- Yeah.
- I just don't think that Michael Jackson
would have been an all
time great litigator.
Or an all time great litigator
would have been a great artist.
- Dude.
- I'm so glad we met.
- Thank you so much man.
- My pleasure, good luck
with everything. Such a pleasure, 100%.
- Thanks for your time. I appreciate it.
- Real pleasure.
Nice to meet you as well.
Ready to rock?
I'm gonna be promoting it 24/7/365.
It's gonna be like, the GaryVee brand.
It's gonna be the new
addition to the brand GaryVee.
It'll just be in my ethos,
and I'm gonna right hook,
buy my brand--
God you can really smell it.
- You can smell it, huh?
- Fuck.
- It's wild how you really can.
- That's a real fucking fire.
Just wanna send all my love,
sorry, I'm doing a vlog.
I just want to send all
my love to my wine friends
in California, especially
in Napa, Sonoma Valley,
it's like I'm over here,
where are we, in Palo Alto?
- Menlo Park.
- Menlo Park and just smell
the ashes, and that whiff
right there just made me think
of all my buddies and all those
nights I've slept up there,
so I just want to wish
everybody, I know a lot of
wine makers and individuals whose
homes are already gone, and warehouses.
My November wine of the month,
zinfandel, for Thanksgiving?
Was in a warehouse the
day before it burned down,
so just a lot of love and...
if for any reason anybody
connected to or former wine
friends in that region are
watching my vlog right
now and I can be of help,
gary@vaynormedia, please let
me know if I can be of help.
Hey vlog, just had an
interesting meeting with a lot
of characters that maybe
you've seen before.
All have been with me for a bunch of time,
two of three of them have been
my assistants, one wasn't.
Anyway, a big Facebook
talk about to go down here
in Menlo Park, looking forward to it.
Good day so far. Productive.
Some pure wow meetings.
We're gonna bang out this talk with
some potential clients
probably, and shoot out to LA.
We're leaving you. Here we go.
- [Bob] You're sitting
across from a client.
A CEO, a CMO, the whole C-Suite,
and you're talking about
what your philosophy and beliefs are.
So you go in, and I think we
all know you're pretty bold,
right, you're very honest,
what is the typical reaction
you get when you talk to a
Fortune 100 company C-Suite?
- It runs the gamut of, first of all,
it's 100% selfish on their side of it,
as it should be, we're
all selfish, we're humans,
so either they view me as something that
can be a benefit to them,
as a gateway to a better job
or a learning or a connection,
but when it comes to
the merit of what I'm talking about,
I think as a human, as Sally and Rick,
after about two or three hours,
I think they agree, or
they intuitively agree.
I think as executive in a
company, they have the politics
of the AOR or things of that nature.
I mean we have real life
stuff, we have people who
look me dead in the face and say,
"I'm desperate to do business with you,
but my CO's best friends
with Martin Sorrell,
and we can't have a non-WPP
agency in this building."
And I'm like, I
understand, because listen,
I get the benefit of somebody wanting
to take a selfie with me and
Vayner Media gets the business.
I understand how the world
works, it's all coming at
the detriment of the
brands, so what do I think?
I think the biggest COs
in the world trade on
when they're retiring and
what the stock prices are when
they retire so that they can liquidate,
and that the things that I require
or beg people to do takes investment.
When you do investment, your stock price
goes down in the short-term,
and that is not as interesting to do.
I think a lot of people aren't really sure
if I'm right or not, am I
completely full of shit or not,
like they're disconnected sometimes from--
I mean, directors of marketing
are disconnected from
the practitioner-ship.
The C-Suite is like, I
think they intuitively know,
and this is why this is the
tone of my conversation,
there's nothing I'm saying
here that not everybody knows,
just not the conversations we're having.
But it doesn't make it wrong.
And I think that's the thing
that I'm passionate about.
And by the way, I started
VaynerX, Vayner Media,
to buy businesses, like I'm
spending a 10 year process
of learning, but I believe
so much in the negative of
what we're actually doing
that I built an entire company
and I'm holding my breath for
a decade to buy the businesses
that are gonna be sold
for a penny on the dollar
once the carnage comes,
which I believe happens in
the next 10 to 15 years.
Like for me, it's super
extreme, like to me,
the reason I want to get
the clients that I want
is cause we do the stuff I believe in.
Sour Patch Kids became
the fastest growing candy
because I got them off TV
and went into Instagram
and Snapchat four years ago
where 12-15 year olds lived.
I'm not a genius, you all
know that's where they live.
Anything you wanna do
for somebody under 30,
how can you possibly do the
traditional above-the-line work?
Or the things that we accept in digital.
I'm more worried about
traditional digital a lot of times
than I am traditional.
There's a lot of things we do in digital
that is accepted on CPM value
that has no practicality,
no context, the creative has no context
to the platform that
it's being delivered on,
which gives us no chance
as true marketers,
and so to me it's just,
I didn't know all of this
seven years ago when
I started the company,
somewhere around two or
three years ago I'm like,
"Oh shit.
Okay. Right.
Nobody's incentivized
to do the right thing for the logo."
And so that's a big opportunity.
And that's what happens,
that's why IBM lets Microsoft happen,
that's why Microsoft lets Google happen.
That's just what happens,
and so I think over
the next 20 years the
Fortune 500 turns over
in an extreme way and I
think that there will be
a book written about the
five holding companies
pulling one of the great business heists
in modern day history
because I think they're
extracting the value out of
the biggest brands in the world
with the advice and strategies
that they're giving.
And honestly, I think good for them,
I don't think it makes them
bad, this is capitalism,
they're doing what's
right for their business.
I'm flabbergasted that the
clients are letting it happen.
- We're gonna go to questions in a minute,
this is too fucking good.
- Just two now, we keep changing.
One thing that has emerged
for me when I speak,
by the way, can someone
do a quick quant run
on how much of the vlog has been in a car?
19.6% of DalyVee, 307 episodes.
89%. Get it man.
Anyway, this is really interesting.
Kind of had that rant the other day about
selling something you believe in.
It's really, I guess I'm
eating my own dog food.
Getting high on my own supply,
just absolutely doing
that every time on stage,
just will not waver no matter how
comfortable or uncomfortable
it is in the short term.
Being historically correct
and saying what I believe
is probably what's most
resonating with you guys, right?
At the end of the day, I feel
like there's a very distinct,
slight difference between me
and the majority of what's out there,
which is not being at the mercy of
this being my livelihood,
gives me the ability to
have a one-track mind,
which is to bring you guys
the most value possible
with no expectation in return.
That's what's happening on stage, man.
I just don't care if they become
Vayner Media clients or not
like everybody else does who talks.
I just don't give a fuck.
- [Cameraman] I know three and a half.
You were in screaming that
that billboard didn't work,
and commercial didn't work.
Why are you so much more confident
and good at what you are?
- I'm just getting closer to my time.
When I first find
something, voice, right now.
Wait until you see how
confident I look on voice
in DailyVee Episode 719.
Like, the part--
- [Cameraman] You play in the
market and then you wait for--
- When I'm early but not
too early, I'm like okay,
here we are, here it is,
but I know those early
days are like, "What?"
- [Cameraman] One thing I like about it...
What you were doing DailyVee
with Patrick, the voice guy--
- Dude, do you understand what
the guys, if you understood.
God if you watched DailyVee
2006, 7, 8, you'd shit.
You'd fucking shit.
No matter what you fucking
think of me right now,
if you saw the shit coming out of my mouth
eleven fucking years ago, that is straight
to the fucking point 100% on,
you still think it's fucking futuristic,
or you take it for granted
cause it's the only way
and don't even realize eleven
years ago people still debated
if social media was going to be a fad.
Alright, I have to go, I love you.
See ya. Bye.
Hello, Phil.
(laughter)
- Walking out of San Francisco
International Airport.
I have no business being here whatsoever,
other than to do another
airport meeting with Gary.
I bought another refundable ticket
to meet him in the
airport, spent 15 minutes.
Make some big moves, got in
there by the skin of my teeth.
(rap music)
- We left Phil at the Facebook meeting.
He rushed here to the airport.
He's not even supposed to be here.
We had out meeting and we
accomplished many great things.
We'll look back at this film and be like,
"Shit, that's where we
made all of our money."
- Yeah. Some of our money.
- And Phil's very optimistic for the Jets
beating the Patriots this weekend.
I am a little less optimistic
but cautiously hopeful.
Phil's 100% confident the Jets will win
because we have chemistry.
- It matters.
(rap music)
- 8:41 here in LA. Makes a long day.
Question of the day is really simple.
What I wanna hear from
you guys on YouTube,
very simply, is what's
top of mind right now?
What's the white space
that you're trying to fill?
And more importantly,
if you're not trying
to fill a white space,
what did this question make you think of?
Answer it.
I'm going to look at every fucking answer.
(rap music)
(laughter)